hey guys I am just here with Christian
at backstreet bakery and we're making
sweet rolls of Skyrim fame I'm so
excited so I think the original recipe
of Stoli go sweet roll of fame is like
eggs and milk and flour and salt that's
not the exact amounts we're not using a
sack of flour or anything like that but
it's all pretty similar we start off
with flour we have five hundred and
forty grams of flour yeah 85 grams of
brown sugar yeah 10 grams of salt okay
and then also 20 grams of yeast right
and then for our liquid semi liquids we
have basically it's about three eggs
we'll beat those before we put them in
and add them into the mix gradually then
we have 190 mils of milk and 270 grams
of butter fantastic okay so this looks
somewhat complicated how complicated
would you say this is I can't bake for a
novice Baker it might be difficult for
some people but if you follow a method
and do everything correctly it should
come out alright so you'll need a couple
of things a mixer is always helpful
doing this by hand would get quite messy
and be very difficult so the what we're
going to start off with is a flour brown
sugar salt and yeast we put this into
our Bowl just add all of those
ingredients and so when we start mixing
this we'll start mixing it with just our
milk alone and we don't want to put all
of our egg in because we'll have two egg
and add the egg in a couple of different
parts but we'll start off with about a
third yeah so 1/3 the egg goes in as
well close that off and then on a
low-speed so everything doesn't fly out
okay we'll just start to bring we'll
just start to bring everything together
and start to form our dough
you
um when I was about a year ago I tried
to make a cake whip from a packet me I
think there were two sips it was at two
eggs and add like 50ml of water did the
eggs forgot the water completely
destroyed it I don't I don't I don't
know why cooking hates me I can make
spaghetti bolognaise and tanking also
only from a package that's right
absolutely disgusting I'm so ashamed of
myself
you
so that's the mixing stage excellent so
then we take that we cover it with you
can use a piece of baking paper and you
actually push the baking paper directly
on to the dough okay cool all right
and then we put this into our
refrigerator and we wait
so these are awesome and just to remind
it you can actually go pick these up if
you're in Sydney from a back street
bakery on October 29 and 30 from 10:00
a.m. it's that fast in best-dressed so
go ask for a sweet roll if you want to
sweet
why wouldn't you want one it's cake and
fondant ok go eat